in his newest challenge as well as the
2018 season it's coming up is the 30th
season of The Amazing Race that he is
partnered with fellow IndyCar racer
Conor Daly good to see you once again
Alexander Rossi be here how are you
brother really good why why would you
get involved the Amazing Race where did
where did that I nod from you know I
mean the offseason six months it's
something different to do no doubt and
then to competitions right do you watch
it I mean you just something that you've
been watching no no so so that was the
thing so like they call it they're like
would you like to do it and I was like
yes what is it so uh okay watch like two
or three seasons in the three week time
period I had to prepare and that was my
Amazing Race
what do you mean prepare I know I know
you're I know you're an athlete you're
your competitor so everything's about
preparation but mostly like by the stuff
like good REI mm-hmm like I didn't
really prepare any other way I had never
been camping before so like I just went
into REI and was like that looks
important have you ever done anything
outside of a cars that we're so
basically what I'm asking you Alexander
I guess not when you put it that way now
okay so now episode one has aired
yes that you you so you are either
sitting here is that will winner of the
30th season of The Amazing Race you're
not but you cannot tell us right right
that's correct
one or the other you know I've only
interviewed you once so I can't tell if
you're giving me a tell right now I'm
not so we went to isolate okay was
amazing I never been before okay
beautiful country would love to go back
one thing that is very disappointing
about reality TV was that episode took
11 hours like from when we land in
Iceland so when we finished and we were
on like television for 50 seconds so
that's the way it works man you missed a
bit but it's okay yeah I mean well
that's just that's honestly the way it
works oh yeah I mean the amount of time
that you spend doing television and then
the amount of time that actually shows
up on the air far far under strips how
long it took and usually you've been
waiting around just to do a minutes
worth of that so you're learning it you
sounds great I'd love to keep racing and
so
what can you tell me what has been the
craziest challenge that you you had to
do for that sort of thing I can't tell
you the challenges I will tell you that
it's it's a very unique show and the
fact that they try and get you as
uncomfortable as possible in a foreign
environment which brings out a different
side of you that definitely are from me
at least it is an on display at a
racetrack right which will either go
down really well or write poorly
depending on which 50 seconds they show
in the episode so it was it was a very
cool experience a lot different than I
expected and yeah happy to be able to do
that to represent the Verizon IndyCar
Series there you go there you go
Alexander Rossi on Twitter as well as
right here in studio so your first race
the seasons coming up in March correct
of 2018 in st. Petersburg what what can
fans of your team expect what what you
had something new going on what are you
watching it's a whole new car for 2018
and so we went back to a spec aero kit
so there's no more manufacturer kids
there's only a Honda or Chevrolet engine
obviously we know which one mm-hmm we're
on the right side we are yes we're on
the side of right correct yes and might
here on the team Honda on the Rich Eisen
shown exactly damn straight
and it's it'll level the playing field
so I'm looking forward to that
okay I haven't driven the new car yet I
will next week for the first time okay
and we have very high hopes okay and so
do you have a college team or you don't
have a college team I don't okay don't
let Graham Rhea all bring you over to
the wrong so don't worry about that
yeah what do you mean why should I not
worry about well because not only does
Graham constantly try and shove Ohio
State in my face and but also like six
of my team members all went to Ohio
State and it's just it out of spite I
just won't good for you like I don't
have any reason not to be a fan but I
just won't refuse - how about can we
take it the next level okay why don't
you just start rooting for Michigan with
me sweet let's do it
I have zero connection to Michigan
that's good except hear what that Tom
Brady and Tom Brady
Tom Brady do that first of all come to
the we already talked about the side of
right and might right okay okay the
head-to-head between Michigan Ohio State
of late let's not talking about that
there it's Michigan what is there like
an animal Wolverines that's good okay
yes they they're they're a nasty
creature and now also just remind remind
gram every single time absolutely who is
the greatest quarterback in the history
of professional football t b12 and what
school did he go to Wolverines go
Michigan yo go blue go blue go blue no
that's okay go blue I'll learn it time
I'm back I'll have always like the
history knowledge I will set you up on
that wonderful what do you think about
all this news about the the Patriots
because you first of all how does one
grow up in Northern California become a
New England Patriot fans like the number
one question I get asked more than like
what was like twenty five hundred like
how did you become a patriot well when I
lived in Europe for six years they only
in I lived in Italy Prague and London
they only televised Packers or Patriots
games before there was NFL access right
yeah so like I had to choose between one
or the other and it's just so you just
chose Patriots yeah I mean it's a 50/50
shot I feel like I chose right okay but
I I mean I grew up only going to 49er
football games just like Tom Brady by
the way correct yep yep California boys
still yes yeah so it was it's not that
you know I'm from Boston or I've only
been to one game it's just that that was
what as I fell in love with football
okay as a teenager that was the team
that I had accessed so what do you could
what do you think about this story
that's out there on ESPN right now
saying that there's a fraction I think
it's interesting
I mean being an athlete and and
understanding a little bit of how the
media works I mean I would say that
there is some element of truth to that
but it's also blown out of proportion
like seemingly every Patriots news
article is they're going to another
Super Bowl mmm it would seem there's
always something right there's always
something that people are upset about or
trying to say how the trains derail
and things are gonna change and be
different and it's like yeah I mean to a
certain extent of course it's not gonna
last forever I don't think it's as
dramatic is it's being made up okay so
you think they're going to win the Super
Bowl this year I think they're gonna go
again I don't necessarily know if
they're gonna win it so who concerns you
Kansas City you know what because they
did win in week one I'll tell you what
that's what the Steeler fans are hoping
for they're hoping that Brady with all
this stuff and fella check with all this
stuff they get one and done by the
Kansas City Chiefs in a couple of
Saturdays now and then Pittsburgh
welcomes them into their house and they
have their number so yeah I mean we'll
see you I mean I don't I don't know the
Eagles are gonna be able to do anything
yeah cuz if Nick Foles they might have a
problem and the Rams out here pretty
damn stout - they're good they are good
that was a shock wasn't it well I mean
that they became this good this fast
with a 31 year old coach but then again
as you know it doesn't matter how old
you are to succeed in sports how'd you
like how I just turned it was nice thank
you do you were 24 years old when you
won the Indy 500 right so you have to do
the math in your own head yeah 525 now
you're cuz you're 26
right you were 24 I don't know stay for
25 just look I you were young yeah you
won the Indy 500 euros 25 I just
finished okay you're a member of a Honda
here on the Rich Eisen show where you
were welcome anytime
appreciate it so come on back certainly
after the Amazing Race season is over
yes we'll talk about that and and maybe
after the Super Bowl talk about your
Patriots winning another one 30th season
of The Amazing Race including Alexander
Rossi the season premiered this past
week on Wednesday night it's every
Wednesday at 8:00 p.m. Eastern on CBS
which I believe is America's most
watched Network
good to see you Alexander rosy and good
luck to you when you start racing
I appreciate you coming up in March the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience